yeah i've known chris for uh close to 20
years our relationship goes back to when
i was at utah and he was the number one
strength coach he had no reservations
hiring him based on the allegations and
and what happened at iowa and
why hire him instead of going in a
different direction
oh sure i i i vet everyone on our staff
and like i said the relationship goes
back close to 20 years and
a lot of hard questions asked a lot of
vetting involved and
uh with the with all our staff but uh
we we
did a very good job vetting that one are
you at all concerned that
him being in the building will impact
your ability to attract free agents
uh i if i was i wouldn't have hired him
uh once again i'll explain that if that
becomes a
question uh the one thing i'm very
confident is that
i would imagine within a year or two of
the best sports performance team in the
national football league
[Music]
they did some careful vetting of chris
doyle but apparently not enough for more
accurately peter they didn't anticipate
the blowback now urban meyer i think had
an inkling i watched very carefully his
press conference from thursday and when
the first question
was coming about chris doyle i detected
a little mini smirk and that kind of
nervous scratching of his face
and he got one question from michael
derocco of
espn.com a follow from him another from
him two questions later mark long of the
ap hit urban with another chris doyle
question and then later multiple
additional questions about chris doyle
that that's the kind of
persistence that maybe he didn't expect
in jacksonville that maybe he had become
accustomed to
life in a college town where you're the
emperor and you really don't answer to
anyone he had to answer to the media and
given what happened on friday night the
ultimate friday news dump after 11 p.m
eastern out came the statement from the
jacksonville jaguars that chris doyle
had resigned only one day after he was
announced as the director of sports
performance chris doyle came to us this
evening to submit his resignation we
have accepted chris did not want to be a
distraction to what we were building in
jacksonville here's the key we are
responsible for all aspects of our
program and in retrospect should have
given greater consideration to how his
appointment may have affected all
involved in other words he didn't resign
voluntarily
we know we screwed up he is now gone and
we shouldn't have hired him in the first
place
and i was stunned
that it came so quickly and my guess is
see one of the things you don't deal
with at the college level is an owner
my guess is shot khan wasn't happy with
what transpired and some pressure was
applied to make this happen on friday
night peter
maybe
um i had two reactions when i woke up
saturday morning number one
i would be extremely surprised i'm not
saying it didn't happen
i would be extremely surprised
if
this was prompted
by this coach coming to urban meyer and
saying you know i don't want to make you
guys look bad i'm going to resign
i mean
really
you know
are you saying that that after you get
all these questions at the press
conference after rod graves of the fritz
pollard alliance with a very
significant statement very significant
statement
talking about how this a great example
of the good old boys network i've known
this guy for 20 years
this
that rod graves statement i can tell you
was significant but but my
my biggest takeaway
is that
you know there's nobody in that
organization
mike who can say to urban might they're
looking at urban meyer as a demigod okay
nobody in that organization can say hey
coach
this is a horse crap decision you can't
do it
you can't do it
and and and maybe he'll say hey go sit
in your cubicle or or whatever
but he needs he's in the nfl can you
imagine this is a guy who got ran out of
ames or iowa city iowa
and you think coming into the nfl that
he's going to be an acceptable hire
is there nobody in the organization who
said now you know urban you know like
there's probably only about a thousand
people
you know who can do what this guy does
and maybe he is the best but you know
what we're gonna have to get the second
best or the fourth best
because we can't do this we can't hire
this guy now mike there's one other
thing i think to to to really remember
in this
and that is that
i don't know that urban meyer other than
having jimmy johnson as his nfl
godfather
i don't know that he has a lot of people
in the nfl who were sort of putting
their arms around him and saying hey
here's my advice about this here's my
advice about that and maybe he's not
asking for it
urban meyer
needs
someone in his organization
that before he makes a decision like
this he just called and says hey what do
you think of this that's what he needs
and he might he might think he has that
now but he doesn't have that now and he
needs one of those people
we all need one of those people in our
lives who can tell us when we're about
to do something extremely stupid so we
don't do it because sometimes you
develop a blind spot take the the clip
from urban meyer from thursday and he
said that he's known chris doyle for 20
years dating back to when i was the head
coach at utah and he was the number one
strength coach well that creates the
impression that they actually work
together they never work together
chris doyle was at utah in 1998 for one
year went to iowa after that and was
there ever since until
whatever it was that transpired last
year that resulted in him accepting a
buyout he's denied any responsibility
but it was an investigation involving
some racially charged statement and
mistreatment of players
but
meyer was there five years later he
created the clear impression they worked
together they had never in their careers
worked together he just knew of him he'd
never worked with him and he may know
him but he never worked with him i mean
it's different to know somebody as part
of the broader coaching industry it's
another thing to grind with him every
single day to observe him to see who he
is how he is who he's really about what
he's really about and he created the
impression that he had that relationship
and he didn't and secondly this is the
thing that caused me to fall out of my
chair on saturday morning because friday
night they sent out the statement 11 18
pm eastern is when it arrived in our
email box
statement from jaguar's head coach urban
meyer the statement we showed on the
screen
saturday morning
9 30 10 o'clock they reissued it
to add trent bauke's name to the
statement the general manager of the
team inadvertently omitted from the
statement are you kidding me you're
going to dust this thing off and reissue
it and create the impression that urban
meyer doesn't want to take the heat by
himself somebody else has to bear the
blame for this so it's not just from me
expressing regret it's also from trent
balcke who who should be the guy who's
in position to say to urban we probably
shouldn't do this and for all we know
did say it his name gets attached to it
on saturday so the black mark goes on
his resume as well peter
i you know the whole thing is just
you know mike
it's just sloppy
the entire process was sloppy
and
that's one of the reasons why i think
is
the jaguars
the jaguars look terrible in this whole
thing
they look absolutely terrible
and
and they they need somebody to come in
and help urban meyer and trent balcke
and shad khan clean up the mess that's
all there is to it it's
they're missing something they're just
missing something and the entire process
just puts an exclamation point on that
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports